you truly never know what you're going
to find when you open a suitcase every
bag tells a
[Music]
story good afternoon Shoppers welcome to
unclaimed baggage the nation's only
retailer of lost luggage Jennifer's
worked at unclaimed baggage for 27 years
and she's witnessed her fair share of
strange findings I think potentially the
weird CEST item we've ever found an
unclaimed baggage was a live rattlesnake
we found him in the side pocket of a
duffel bag we released Mr rattlesnake
and he may still live today who knows
over the years the weird items piled up
so the team opened a museum in store to
Showcase their Priceless finds over 100
items are on display we have suits of
armor we have a Michael Jordan
autographed basketball we have things
that predate Christ by hundreds of years
there was a suitcase in the 1980s in
fact it was a Gucci suitcase and when we
opened it it was filled with Egyptian
artifacts you're probably wondering how
all this stuff ended up in scotsboro
Alabama the airlines do an incredible
job of reuniting people with their
unclaimed bags in fact they're
successful over 99 a half% of the time
but when they are millions of people
traveling every single day that fraction
of 1% really adds up and that's where we
step in after 90 days unclaimed baggage
rescue those orphan bags items are
sorted into three categories things to
be resold in store donated to charity or
recycled this is Brian the CEO he's
lived and breathed unclaim baggage his
whole life my dad started unclaim
baggage when I was in the sixth grade
Back in
1970 one day he was on the radio talking
to a friend in Washington DC and he said
we have more unclaimed bags and we know
what to do with so my dad thought I
could do something with those and so he
borrowed $300 from one of my
grandfathers and a 1965 Chevy pickup
truck from the other grandfather and
went off and bought his first load of
bags in the early days he got the the
the bags from Trailways bus lines and
then moved into the airlines a few years
later I work there afternoons Summers
weekends holidays my brother was
involved my mom was involved so it was
it really was truly a family business
unclaimed baggage has grown from one man
in his truck to a store the size of a
city block and they've welcomed millions
of people through their doors including
a few return customers my name is Alan
Garner and I'm a regular Shopper at
unclaimed baggage I remember going there
at first time when I was 9 years old my
grandmother took me down there I
remember kind of the the scavenger hunt
uh even back then I do have a routine
most days you know I I park at the back
go through those bins and then I'll come
into the main building usually swing by
the shoes check out the shoes go up to
the mezzanine look at some Electronics
video games Sporting Goods I'll swing
back down maybe hit some clothes racks
and then I'm out the door headed home so
how much treasure have you found Alan
I'm not going to say tens of thousands
but but I know thousands of items my
wife has told me before I buy anything
I've got to call and ask her first my
most prized find um is no longer in my
possession a couple of years ago I
bought a fishing reel paid $4.95 for it
it was a $700 reel but I got to looking
at it and I found a man's name on it and
so I was able by Google and research to
find that man and so I ended up mailing
his reel back to him and it was just at
a time in his life to where he had lost
his wife he really didn't want to go
fishing but he went fishing and he lost
his reel going to the airport and so I
was able to make a friend he's invited
me to uh to his hometown to fish with
him at some time and so you know that's
probably my most favorite find because I
was able to get that back to him but not
everything is for sale over a third of
items found are donated to
Charities thousands of eyeglasses
wheelchairs medical supplies and clothes
are given to people in need and the
store has started its own program love
luggage providing personalized suitcases
for foster children moving into new
homes who would have thought that A
stranger's lost bag could bring so much
joy the the old saying of one man's junk
another man's treasure we're all wired
the same way to where we're looking for
that
[Music]
treasure